tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo video
sono fa vj oggi sono tratti su grand
theft auto 5 ciao [ __ ] come sta che
cosa cazzo cioè in faccia se sto
guardando niente con i cetrioli bella
brava sia di tipo e se deve entrare in
casa illuminati sul muro comunque
ragazzi e scivoli clonati o un amico ma
ecco belli sola per aprire le porte
benissimo da un pezzo che non giocavo lì
ma oggi pianta altro non è che bel culo
cia sta tizia da sculacciate raccolta
zia sin troppo lurida [ __ ] vieni qui
dove cazzo
ho picchiato un tizio non voleva
picchiare lui ascolta zione stavo
scherzando stavo scherzando stavo
schiavo in quasi tutta la gang sti
bastardi ma che cazzo vuoi tu non
toccate ma [ __ ] piaga via veloce
veloce
la gang contro di me please ascolta zia
no no no è tranquilla tranquilla ente
corre le cose io volevo semplicemente
dirti che mi ha ignorato quindi volevo
darti nou dove cazzo mondi quella
[ __ ] [ __ ] nuovo culo che ti ammazzo
la famiglia la polizia è passata ma
intanto ti investo uguale se ancora viva
perché al noe morte morte ma li passiamo
ci sono poche bella ciccio guarda altri
poiché tiene sulla macchina belli tutto
nel culo la prossima volta
i ragazzi è passato il treno mentre
andavo devo assolutamente trovare quel
[ __ ] 39 posso treno rocce carpe diem
sicché dic una assurda sono dentro sé
ragazzi e centrare il buco è la cosa più
difficile della storia posto zio ha
fatto male lui vive una roccia che si fa
mai un cazzo di sky andare avanti
trattando per inter è stato memorabile
raga non riuscirò mai a rifarlo neanche
tra vent'anni però ok selis per andare
nella cappa passo toglie letizia dalla
cabina e sono caduto come un [ __ ]
non sapremo mai così riesco a salire
veloce perfetto è mai ma io sono avanti
in queste cose non c'è bisogno la
propaggine della madonna
lei che è che pazzo di molo li si ke
kazzo fatto è morta dove vai dove vai
vai ti voglio dare un abbraccio zia
vieni qua della madonna
la polizia che mi ha visto non si sa
come ma ok fate rubare una macchina
no lui è ficcato anche a tua moglie
bravo grazie molto gentile e stato
bellissimo comunque devo rifarmi una
volta madonna lo slalom lo slalom come
cosa ho schivato non sono anche bello
complimenti siamo quasi a venice beach
ragazzi ormai riconosco tutte le zone
merci sono stato los angeles a memoria
che cazzo è uguale identico è assurdo
c'è ormai sto dove sto andando senza mai
guardare la mappa scusa fratello scusa
sorella cioè ragazzi cè un mio amico sul
balcone cazzo non sapevo che fosse quale
edizione ebbene si come stai e scendi il
cane che lo fisso verso l'infinito e
oltre al fratello non devi cup devi
capire che non puoi guardarti
l'orizzonte da solo dai che fa 6 cagando
ora che il bagno ce l'hai dentro
fratello non è che hai visto cosa hai
visto
lo so che il bagno e dentro ma se vuoi
della compagnia perché si sentiva solo
cago anch'io così siamo pari d'aiuti non
ti sentirai mai più soldi posso andare
qua sopra
mi dispiace ragazzi sto facendo un
parkour pazze sta andando adesso faccio
mirror's edge praticamente ragazzi la
macchina la macchia la prende in pieno
banzai bellissimo grazie grazie e molto
gentile signora anzi guarda sembra
presto ma che bella è sta canzone regal
me la ricordo ancora scusa sia da
ricordi to aspetta che io chiedo quanta
fratella è morta era affezionata la mia
macchina vele devo dare da mangiare a
sta povera christina di una macchina
away semi wyman dove cazzo vai che cantò
da dio io ma [ __ ] non ti piace
come canto bastardo non ti piace non lo
dico una cosa come ti permetti canta tu
fammi vedere che sei meglio di phil
jones bene ecco questa la mia macchina
vini soliti dal cazzo è stato perfetto
per caso ragazzi provava a fare una cosa
stranissima prova a fare il fuggitivo se
riesco a scappare dalla polizia più
possibile a prima di tutto ci sarà una
macchina perché sono core cazzo come
sposiamo ecco la nicchia il culo e
dopodiché ragazzi andiamo con quale
l'altro fuggitivo
ci siamo ragazzi sono livello di stelle
cielo adesso devo scappare o riuscire a
scappare la cosa è alquanto difficile
sono convinto alias esco a fare più di
dieci metri senza crepare con cinque
stelle di difficoltà vai così levatevi
ritorno bastardi bellacci c'è una lotta
in meno ma me ne sbatto i [ __ ] devo
riuscire a sopravvivere almeno un minuto
cosa è cosa di merda ho fatto neanche
volendo riesca a faccia cosa devo
buttarmi giù bye bye bye bye perfetto
sono salvo il treno mica che tutti si
buttano giù bellissimi ragazzi già passo
niente nascondere dritto cazzo
all'avvocato tre ruote il traino raga
non ci sto credendo se riesco a salire
sul treno la persona più felice del
mondo mi fate come prima come prima come
ho fatto prima amica non ce la farò mai
di nuovo impossibile a meno che non
abbia un culo di quelli che poi la metà
basta ci prova ragazzi non vi prometto
niente ma cipro se io scendo da questa
cazzo di macchina mi ammazzano in 27
mila persone cioè impossibile ma è
veloce veloce che cazzo fai aspetti la
suocera
si vabbè ce la fa a passare sul cazzo
chi cazzo fa bene bravo bravo e cazzo
sei un fenomeno 07 in azione a jason
bourne e anzi meglio dire se riesco a
cadere dall'alto mentre sono
ricercatissimi para papa tanta tanta
tanta tanta pescando dal cielo cioè la
colonna sonora perché sarah non funziona
sto vedendo se riesco a cadere con
cinque stelle ma non cambia un cazzo
perché ancora non hanno inventati i
poliziotti piccioni quindi col cazzo che
mi prendete una cosa non ho toccato per
la faccia sopravvivere il casco qua no
però ci ha provato anche bertola ma mi
chiami rilassati brutto sta cosa non so
perché posso prendere un elicottero
mentre casco perché la mira la mira
incredibile porca [ __ ] chiuso mancato
dal cicr e michelon mancato di un cazzo
di niente la polizia e la paura che mi
segue questa bastardi come faccia non lo
voglio rifare regalo voglio rifarmi ne
frega niente dove i temi che ce n'è un
altro ecco bastardo vieni qui non press
non ci credo come cazzo fatta mancare
colori prima mi è passato tanto così già
faccia fare fuggitivo di qua ma si va a
fan culo cadiamo ne frega niente
lacco nell'arco globe e cosa fa sono
vivo ok
spiegatemi perché quando sbattuto contro
il ponte sono sopravvissute quando sono
caduto nell'acqua che problemi c'hai
dove sono passati da che voglio un
ralenti a prescindere abella del sì ma
tu sai chi cazzo sono è visto dove sono
passati ha apposto i prezzi il telefono
allora sei [ __ ] e sai che cosa faccia
le [ __ ] faccio questo pazzo di vogue
usa mi non vuoi allora stai tranquilla
cioè una rom che ofanto fa sta roba
sveden attimo tu non puoi parlare è
vabbè sono caduto sto bene signore sto
molto bene tranquillo posso passare in
mezzo grazie che con recco che corre che
cosa fa quello è un suicida è un sicilia
ti uccido io e si è spostato sto sono
come cazzo ti stai per me come eva
allora sei stronzo devi morire vecchia
che botta a san menaio sinistra allora
senti no eh la madonna piazza un
incontro di presley bra e lo picchia
è stato lui io non ti ho picchiato la
macchina è stato lui vuole menahrem e
enel dei nel frattempo viene minato
dall'altro è bellissimo cassete
meravigliosi ma dona che kartell agli
attirato ragazzi sta e morto stai
tranquillo adesso ci penso io a te ce la
possiamo fare ad andare veloci che bello
che non ha mai veramente un'altra mi
sono spuntate le red bull ti mette le
ali cazzo però non funziona
cara signora corra parola che ci sono
stronzi che volano ok
mica che cazzo è successo davvero
ragazzi proprio l'ultima volta a vedere
se riesco a fuggire l'asi stronzi costa
macchina è l'ultima che mi lo sapevo lo
so ci avrei scommesso la vita è l'ultima
occasione che ciao ragazzi per riuscire
a fare una cosa un po più decente ma so
che non sarà così
non so perché ciò sto presentimento di
morisse la famiglia posso farli in prima
persona no perché non mi conviene
beh in fa dove cazzo sono pub affanculo
ma niente ragazzi a non è giornata
azzurra volevo provare a giocare online
con che preserva sono in manutenzione
[ __ ] tutto ho provato a fare una
partita lo stesso è stato fantastico
l'importante è che io abbia imparato
cose nuove istruttive e che possano
servire in futuro anche nella vita reale
tipo capire come far felici le persone
ad esempio lanciarsi così che fa felice
un po di persone zia vuoi essere felice
oggi guarda a posto ti è migliorata la
giornata visto che è felice sta correndo
a dirlo sua mamma quindi ragazzi spero
che ai video vi sia piaciuto io concluso
qui l'episodio scusa zia non volevo se
il video è piaciuto come al solito certo
momento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come ogni video trovate né
descrizione sauris i fischietti cv
diavolo passioni bella ragazzi